welcome back to new rockstars obi-wan
kenobi episode three gave us our first
real look at darth vader in this series
and while this rematch of kenobi invader
was hardly the duel of the fates part
two we know that these two are destined
to beat again
again and this time obi-wan better bring
that ruckus to that battle because uh
he's got to step it up because uh he got
he got dragged through the sand which is
um
darth vader's greatest enemy he he
weaponized his greatest enemy to use
against obi-wan my god he's angry this
is rogue theory the show where we pitch
the wildest theories for the nerdy
titles that we love my name is mt and
going rogue with me today is someone who
will never to ever take a ride with some
random mole man snitch it's jessica
clements what's going on jess dude
when you said the intro darth vader said
give me something to break and he
snapped that guy's neck
no
um definitely doesn't need to go to
a chiropractor oh after that that man
feels he's like oh i can oh my god i can
smell better like he's like
everything hit that man he's also in
heaven
he was a ghost he's like nothing hurts
anymore oh
because i'm not on the mortals
and a man who will literally drag his
nemesis over the coals it's tom
michelson what's going on tom hello
there that was my uh i want to be
grievous uh hello that was great guys
just imagine that was amazing and yeah
that's what that was uh yeah i'm i'm
ready i'm ready to uh to talk some uh
kenobi talk some uh burning coals uh
for obi-wan
let's do this let's go
let's go let's go and a guy who swears
that laser fences are clearly an osha
violation it's obscure producer brandon
what's going on brandon yo that fence
was messed up you can't have people
working around that thing my favorite
part was when obi-wan he tries to switch
it doesn't work he shoots it just turn
it off you could have just walked around
the edge of that fence you don't gotta
the fence isn't stopping anything it
doesn't work like that totally you could
totally see that there was a a little
path that all the soldiers were walking
by oh my god like i feel like obi-wan
just wanted to see another man chopped
in half it was just like i mean that was
nasty that poor stormtrooper man he's
just doing it i'm loving all of these
gnarly like deaths in star wars shows
because uh when when the mandalorian
kicked off we got that crazy door death
which is one of my favorites oh we're
getting chopped in half this other guy
popped in half yeah darth vader's a guy
you can go hug at disneyland and they
got him breaking people's necks
after okay two things two things really
quick brandon brandon has bring this up
so many times and it is very true it
wasn't until he brought it up to me the
first time where i was like that's hella
true he's probably the most villainous
person in star wars and you can just go
like take a picture with him look at
shirts that are like yeah i'm his father
and it's like so you're the killer like
what yeah exactly you're the murderer
this guy's a murderer darth vader is
literally space hitler uh times like ten
thousand and people are like oh my god
it's my favorite this man come on kids
will take a picture
i don't
know dressing up at halloween that's
insane
honey go see if he'll choke you go see
if he'll choke you
i was at celebration and of course there
were a lot of there were a lot of darth
vader's walking around and i saw so many
with little kids like cheese with this
darth vader guy but i hope i better hope
he doesn't bring out the juggling slayer
9000. you know
yes i'm not trying to be that person but
be wary be cautious of the child that
bee lies to darth vader for photos
before pluto before goofy before any of
the princesses be cautious of the child
that's like
sprinting at the stormtrooper that's the
one that needs therapy the most
it's me
[Laughter]
but yeah we are 10 years past the events
of revenge of the sith everybody and in
that time darth vader has grown stronger
and even more vicious but how much of
his legend has spread across the galaxy
which leads us to our first topic of
today
what is darth vader's reputation
in the galaxy and is the fact that darth
vader is anakin skywalker even a secret
because we learned in the second episode
that riva aka the third sista knows that
darth vader is anakin skywalker so is
she the only one who knows this and did
she find out on her own or did vader
tell her and what does the galaxy know
about darth vader in this point in the
skywalker saga take it away mta first
off i just want to say i love you
because you didn't say the third sister
you said the third sister
when you said that
i said he didn't even notice that he did
that he let him know he let him know oh
we all know yeah i let him know you
gotta let him know
okay
i like the idea that like he's darth
vader is still not
because by the time a new hope comes
around like everyone knows about darth
vader right there they got to build a
death star
they're bad people right i think like
the empire's still trying to be like
good like oh we're fixing your economy
we're putting order in the system so
like i think they have no idea
especially in like the outer rim right
this little planet that we were on uh
uh moosa power or whatever it was called
uh marzipan
marzipan yes
so when those villagers look out the
window and they're like okay
stormtroopers we've seen those we've
heard of these inquisitors who's that
guy with the helmet and he's pulling
people out of houses and breaking their
necks they're probably like they have no
idea what to even call him and it's just
like it's insane and they're like what
is this who is this guy who is this man
whose man is this
who's friend
whose dad is yes
someone stop him i'm not gonna stop him
he just twisted his wrist and broke a
man's neck
right i think people don't know about
darth vader until they meet him and then
they know about him and then they're
probably dead yes and then they know
about him word of mouth spreads fast and
i agree with brandon i think that no one
really knows except for the inquisitors
people that are close to him clearly
know that it's like anakin and know that
it's the because he was in the like back
to tank right that was like he was in
some sort of goo but like do people even
know who anakin is like do they care i
feel like people know what he did during
order 66 so i think people remember him
for that or and maybe not all because
some people got away some some jedi's
got away right so they know anakin
probably killed some people
but they're not like telling the story
right because they don't want to say
like i was there i'm a jedi because then
people would be like oh there's a jedi
right there
that guy's a jedi
he's burned but trust me that's him yeah
yeah
this actually ties into this other
theory that i have about who riva is
i think that i agree with brandon that
you know nobody knows who darth vader is
being anakin i think uh because even
kenobi thought that he killed that and
cannot move so far but i wonder if you
know riva is one of the younglings in
the temple the day that anakin came in
and maybe she saw anakin
killing people so maybe even the other
inquisitors don't even know uh because
because if and if that makes if that's
true then i think it makes sense why the
grand inquisitor and the fifth brother
keep talking down to her because they're
like you came up from the gutter like
you're a jedi youngling and you know
like talking down her about being a jedi
and if they knew that the boss was a
jedi or former jedi that joke might not
uh you know it might not go over very
well so i feel like
riva was one of the younglings uh who
who witnessed the who witnessed attic
and killing people and that's why she
knows and then that ties into kind of
getting off topic but i feel like in the
show
she wants kenobi because she knows
kenobi while getting kenobi will get her
an audience with vader and then she'll
try to get vengeance on her master and
friends getting killed and trying to
kill vader
that's what that's what my
theory about about who she is and what
she's doing and that ties into why she
wants kenobi so bad she doesn't care
about kenobi she cares about vader what
if she didn't see anakin technically
slay but anakin saved her so she's like
anakin was the only person that was like
willing to save me and then
and then vader vader could be like by
the way you know that guy kenobi hate
him and then riva could be like yeah we
hate him yeah i like that too yeah we
don't yeah we hate him yeah we hate him
i think i think going with what brandon
was saying i think people maybe don't
know anakin and don't know the story
like because you're assuming the entire
galaxy would know the story of anakin
which is not like
it doesn't matter yeah because the
empire is controlling the narrative
right now right they're like the
empire's out there they're like all jedi
are bad we got to kill the jedi
don't don't worry about these
inquisitors using the force that's
different but if it's a jedi you're the
good guy
so they don't want to say like force you
they don't want to say their top dog is
a former jedi right they're just like oh
this is a robot monster named darth
vader who can also use the force right
but i also think if you just went to
like a person in the galaxy random
person in the galaxy and you were like
yo darth vader is anakin skywalker
they'd be like i don't know who the
[ __ ] skywalker is so i don't care
who the [ __ ] is anakin skywalker but
they know darth vader probably by now
especially 10 years later yeah maybe
like it's a big deal for luke to find
out but if you told anyone else would
they even care well i think i think
you're right time that riva knows
has fig put it put two and two together
and i think the end of this series she's
gonna be like sitting next to darth and
be like you know darth i know you're
anakin skywalker and he's gonna be like
what the hell did you just say to me and
just be like
you're dead yeah you don't don't say a
word in my face yeah yeah did you just
say the a word to me
i have no name and then just slices her
yeah that'd be i would be so mad at that
anti-climactic
storyline for her i'd be so bad if she
just gets sliced that i think he's
keeping her clothes to use her as a pet
i think he's gonna keep her closer as a
pet because she is so she is literally
like this is like rick and morty type
stuff like she is literally like the
daughter and he's rick like she's just
trying to please him and i think like
she's willing to do whatever it takes
like her stealing baby leia is gonna be
like i got you a toy and he's gonna be a
good job and she's gonna be like
run away
come sit next to me yeah
and i'm like
my favorite daughter ah if vader gets
within touching distance of leia i'm
gonna start crying i'm gonna cry hard
dude because he doesn't know he has no
idea he doesn't deserve it
if he was that close he doesn't feel
like he would know but yeah who knows
he might sense it for a second maybe he
might be close they'll like pass by and
he'll sense it for a second no there's
no way there's no way oh he's gonna
figure i feel like it also obi will
probably tell him like ob like we're
best friends because remember he runs
into her again at the very beginning of
a new hope and he doesn't know right
there he doesn't know right then and at
return of the jedi he actually he didn't
know either because he goes when he's
like taunting luke he goes sister you
have you yes
and that's when he finds out so actually
he shouldn't well if he's still he's
here no but actually that's true he was
he was right in front of her brandon
you're right at a new hope so being
close wouldn't necessarily give it away
but uh but yeah he wouldn't know that
that's the daughter until the turn maybe
he might feel it but i think he's like
put it away i don't know yeah maybe i
mean there's a lot of like retconning
going on after a new home yeah yeah
like i i don't think that darth vader is
gonna know about like leia and that
connection but like cause we know in the
comics that like he actually only
figures out about luke from like i don't
know some like i think bounty hunter
action i forget how he found out but
like he finds out through the grapevine
there's a comic book
that happens like right after
a new hope where he sends boba fett to
figure out who this guy was who launched
a torpedo into the exhaust tube who's
this great fighter ace plus he felt
something when he was flying he's like i
want to know who this guy is because i
think he assumes he's a jedi and and
uh boba fett tells them like uh it's
this dude named skywalker and vader like
isn't standing in front of a window and
he like breaks the window with the force
yes but like holds it together so he
doesn't get sucked out into space
because i think that's when he's like
a skywalker who
i've got kids
and i was just next to both of them
yeah but yeah but i really want cause
like we we see the um you know padme's
tease in episode one or two i believe
episode two and i think that i really
want padme and natalie portman to come
back as like a forced ghost or something
just to talk to leia he's like i think
that'd be really nice now
i don't want her i don't want her to
this might be the villa i have a pair of
scissors this might be the villain
but i don't want her i don't want padme
to come back because i am so obsessed
with the family she has now and i think
if we do have padme come back it's more
of a baby leia being like
i want my real parents it's like your
real family's here and your family is a
great family love them be with them
teach her like that this is her family
don't push her away and i feel like
showing padme is just like
makes it worse makes it harder for a
ten-year-old to understand a
five-year-old actress in a 10 year old
scene
that's just sad i still think they could
do it and maybe bring her back for
anakin's you know like visions and stuff
like i'm still i would still love to see
that too empty to see to see her come
back and anakin have visions and also in
his mind that you know if he's if he
sees himself in his mind he'll see
himself almost like his old self anakin
and that way we can see hayden
christensen doing some stuff behind the
mask that would be really cool i was
also hoping for some flashbacks with him
and obi-wan from the clone wars i mean
it still could happen but some
live-action flashbacks of the clone wars
would be so dope of them fighting side
by side being being bros yeah i mean
this is this is this is a side note and
not part of the question mt so i
apologize but like when obi-wan was in
the truck with lane he was like i wish i
was your dad that was a little
it was a little
i mean because there was always that
thing did you not like it
no i liked it but then i always died
in the prequels about like you know
obi-wan shipping obi-wan and padme right
like
chemistry or whatever and actually
anakin got real jealous about it right
and it's like
was that getting jealous of that yeah
yeah honestly i can like i don't i don't
think that obi-wan was in love with
padme but i can see obi-wan having some
type of attraction towards padme for
sure because like we know that like he
was in love with sateen in the from um
the clone wars show and she was like an
authority figure she was like you know
very much very much like batman a lot of
ways so i can tell you she was a rebound
because he couldn't have paddled you
think
his master qui god was out there he was
definitely getting some was breaking the
rules all right no for sure and he knows
anakin he knows anakin's breaking the
rules and getting some and he's like
what am i doing what's happening
are you saying that uh college just got
snaped uh
the obi-wan kenobi
obi-wan is severus snape
basically
but he got a type mt you know he likes
are you saying he likes you know rulers
queens of the planet strong women that's
a type he's got to type that
those braids yeah exactly i'm all about
it too
i just thought it was more so that like
if he was if he was the father it was
more so like like oh i wish i was your
dad because then anakin wouldn't have
been crazier but i wouldn't have to go
kill my best friend yeah he said i would
have i we were brothers i took it i took
it more of like i wish you i wish i was
your dad because your dad's a crazy
murderer who's trying to kill us and i
would be better than as opposed i don't
want to tell you that but i see what you
mean like there was that was a half
second for me where i'm like that's a
weird way of saying oh he's trying to be
nice okay it wasn't then it went right
into it yeah so i feel you brandon i
feel you on that
i think this like second fight that
vader and obi-wan have too vader's
totally gonna get the upper hand again
and obi-wan is gonna be down bad he's
gonna be going for that final blow and i
think that's where the ghost of padme
shows up and she's like no don't do it
and like that might
instead of padme it is baby leia i i
really wanted to be baby lay in the
inner beans and i want her to use her
little force for a second i wanted to
use a little force for a second and then
that's when like everyone's just shook
everyone's shook and stops for a minute
and then he gets that blow he gets out
that would be nuts because we know how
anakin rolls in the temple with the
younglings and so if we see another kid
you're like don't do it vader that would
be crazy actually i i just feel like if
anakin were to like but i was about to
like give obi-wan the killing blow and
like little leia stops him i feel like
he would stop because he sees padme
within her face like within like because
all kids kind of look like their parents
so like you would probably see pam and
be like why do i care about you
this is weird
it's like i'm not gonna do this and like
i don't know why
no no you're right i have so many ideas
for this and it goes into our second one
our second topic because it kind of ties
in with
the hiding the the force okay sorry keep
going keep going i won't spoil it but
back to the topic it's definitely
talking about all this uh shipping of
different obi-wan and in padme even
though i can totally see it i can
totally see it for sure um i think that
in general um like you guys are right
like i feel like the inquisitors pretty
much only know who
the uh darth vader is and like that he's
anakin skywalker and we in from the
comics we sort of see that like the the
inquisitors are sort of darth vader's
children in a way it's like he's sort of
in charge of them and so like they kind
of hang out like on a semi-regular basis
like the fortress inquisitorius seems to
be like where they all ha darth vader
has like a they're not tight but like i
feel like he's just like i'm the man in
charge and like you guys are my yeah
they have the same they have the same
break room right right
they share the same water cooler yeah
well it's kind of like babysitting them
too right the emperor put them together
yeah to kind of to kind of like [ __ ]
with vader and be like i i got all these
little inquisitors and you got to be in
charge of yeah vader's like i don't want
to do this i hate these guys
that's why he doesn't mind when they die
all the time he's like yeah
also these guys might try to come at me
and take over yeah that's like the whole
sith thing it's like you got secret
apprentices all over the place because
you know you're you're your master's
about to kill you rule of two but
there's 30 of us here yeah these were
all amazing theories as always and i do
think that you know that the only in the
inquisitors really know who darth vader
is cause like if everyone in the galaxy
knew it would sort of just be weird and
like
for luke not to know who darth vader
really was so like i feel like it makes
sense for just the inquisitorius to have
that information because darth vader's
not gonna really share that with
everybody because why would he because i
feel like there was a freedom in in
knowing that um in people thinking that
you're dead especially if you uh killed
all the jedi
which is uh
that helps
yeah a lot of people saw that he's got a
lot of back taxes he doesn't want to pay
yeah he walks back he's like did you
sell the jedi dead weird that's crazy
who did that who did that oh my god oh
weird i heard some really handsome guy
killed all the jedi
he's got all his arms and legs he's got
all his hair he's really happy he was so
hot would you like to see this photo
album of how hot he used to be i mean
it's not hot because of fire like
sexually hot yes
yeah sexually hot anyone says because of
fire as well who knows
you too
who gets the points
i'm gonna give everybody 20 000 points
because everyone had really great ideas
for this one you guys are all smart
cookies for star wars yum yum yum yum
yum smart cookies that grogoo will eat
um after he steals it from you but i'm
not cookie we are going to talk about
the empire hunting down all of them poor
poor jedi um people and children but
first be sure to check out new
rockstars.com to grab our latest
obsession shirt empire's most wanted
inspired by obi-wan kenobi the show like
all of our latest obsession shirts this
one is limited edition and will be gone
faster than the grand inquisitor in
episode two and unlike him this shirt
won't be seen again and when you
purchase a ladies obsession shirt you
unlock a chance to get a custom shout
out on wikileaks our obi-wan kenobi
after show hosted by the lovely eric
voss on the amazing hobby that told so
check out all of our amazing and awesome
obi-wan kenobi merch available at
newrockstarsmerch.com we also want to
thank expressvpn for sponsoring this
video because we've all used incognito
mode on our browsers before i mean not
me i'm a christian boy but what you read
[Laughter]
you can use it for other things that
means he's used it extra maybe
exactly when i'm looking at my bible
verses i don't want people to know which
bible verses i'm looking at you know
what i'm saying that's perfect
well using cognitive mode on our
browsers before but did you ever read
the fine print that appears when you
start browsing incognito it says that
your activity might still be visible to
your employer your school your internet
provider that's a lot of people knowing
what you're googling about feet to
really stop people from seeing the site
that you visit you need to do what i do
and use expressvpn to keep your activity
on the low because think about all the
times you use wi-fi at a cafe a hotel or
even your parents house which is worse
than a cafe without expressvpn every
site that you visit could be logged by
the admin of that network even when you
use incognito mode people can be
watching what you're doing don't do that
and what's more your home internet
provider like att or verizon they can
also see and record your browsing data
why that's not nice and in the us
they're legally allowed to sell that
data to advertisers so you can get
capitalism what not cool expressvpn is
an app that encrypts all of your network
traffic and reroute it through their
secure servers so that your online
activity stays private expressvpn is
easy to use the app literally has a big
old on button you tap it and you turn it
on and that's it it works on all your
devices phones computers and even your
router so your whole family can stay
private under one subscription so stop
letting people invade your online
privacy today and protect yourself with
the number one rated vpn at
expressvpn.comrode and use our link
expressvpn.comrogue to get three extra
months free that's express e x p r e s s
vpn dot com slash rogue to learn more
when i'm watching content or listening
to music on my phone i want to be able
to hear everything and that's why i use
my raycon wireless earbuds to do all of
that they're actually right here wow i
actually do use these
i use my raycons because they're amazing
raycon's everyday earbuds look feel and
sound better than ever with optimized
gel tips for the perfect in-ear fit
these earbuds are so comfortable and
will not budge from your ear hole trust
me i've tried to shake them out of my
ear holes they won't come out they're
actually still in there i just keep them
in there uh because i don't like my ear
holes exposed to uh caterpillars that
could just crawl in and take over my
mind i saw a peacemaker not a fan so
raycons offer three sound profiles to
match what you're listening to plus
noise isolation and awareness mode so
you can choose to be immersed in sound
or be able to hear your surroundings
when you need to which is very handy
when you're you know walking amongst the
populace you don't want a lion to attack
you out of nowhere because you'll hear
the growls because you got awareness
mode on they give me the premium sound
experience that i crave and i need it
because you know watching things is just
better with sound and just listening
just i like the sound inside of my body
and raycons give you eight hours of play
time and a 32 hour battery life then
when you need to charge it's super easy
you can just even just do it wirelessly
it's amazing and with raycons you get
the same quality audio as other premium
audio brands but at half the price and
it's no wonder raycon's everyday earbuds
have over forty nine thousand five star
reviews a lot of five star reviews so go
to buy raycon dot com slash rogue theory
today to get 15 off your raycon order
that's by recon dot com slash rogue
theory to score fifteen percent off by
raycon dot com slash rogue theory all
right gang
now let's talk about this next topic
because in this episode of obi-wan
kenobi tala mentions the empire's
constant hunt for force sensitive
individuals including children which
leads us to our second topic for today
how is the empire finding all of these
force sensitive individuals like are
they going around and testing
midi-chlorian counts or are they just
waiting for kids to just start showing
of their force sensitive abilities
through puberty or i don't know some
type of x gene or something so what are
they doing with all these force
sensitive kids that they take what do
you guys think well brandon help me with
this um this is going to be me and
brandon's thought together so if brendan
has a joint thought
this is a brandon and jessica joint
oh and tommy joint so okay so all of us
are going to share these points at the
end of the day okay so people that are
very trained in the force can probably
sense the force in other people and
other jedis or people that do have the
force can hide theirs if they're heavily
trained so it shouldn't be hard to find
like a child's force right because
they're not heavily trained like someone
like darth darth sidious is right
like it would be easier to find a child
with a force than someone with older
with the force and i know that liam
neeson kind of found anakin by
mistake kind of like just being like
just because this kid survived a pod
race doesn't mean it's a jedi but i
guess
oh he's so sick at polar racing he's the
one
he was like what the hell was that that
child has some special abilities
but um but i think it's easier if i
think they're using the inquisitors to
help find force sensitive people because
they're highly trained
and they can sense it right
i'm i'm asking insane as my theory
that first scene right in the the first
episode she's in the town and she's like
i know that he's in this bar or whatever
but that was mainly because she saw the
lightsaber strikes on the wall and she
couldn't tell where he was
you know he was still sitting there it's
not like you you did it i mean that's
true they can probably feel it when
they're around i also think it might
just be like a bs thing where they show
up and they're like we know that there's
a force sensitive person here you guys
need to write them out we're going to
start killing people and they just be
like that one that guy right there that
is whether he's force sensitive or not
they got him
but it's it's kinda and honestly
honestly they probably learned that from
darth vader they're like uh he just
walks through snapping next i should be
able to just come in and accuse someone
at least i'm not killing them
immediately i'm just accusing
but uh she she she can read minds right
she's reading minds i was gonna say it's
your point to your point just yeah she
can like even like kylo ren like they
can they can read minds and kylo when
he's trying to read rey knew in that
moment oh snap like she got the force
too so sure there's they can kind of
read and feel and detect all of that but
are they gonna go to every planet in the
system and check every single person
that's not efficient get the blood test
you have midichlorian blood tests just
test everybody
but i think if you if you get bigger and
this is the mindset that i think uh
they're using is if we become big enough
on each planet there will be our own
versions of ourselves correct that's how
i feel like a tyrant would handle it of
being like if we branch out there's
gonna be more like us in different
planets on different cities so i think
they're like yeah the blood's not gonna
work and it's gonna be very aggressive
to be like give me that blood but like i
think they're gonna just be there and be
like since since since since everyone's
gotta go to the doctor at some point
test the blood poor you know not
everybody's going to the doctor poor
george lucas finally answered the
question of where the force came from
comes from midichlorians and what did we
do as a fan base we got mad at him and
we said that's dumb that's stupid but it
makes so much sense go test everybody
bro i was thinking about midi chlorines
this morning and honestly i really want
to learn more about how the mini
chlorians relate to the force because i
honestly feel like they're not they
don't cause the force but like what if
they're just like little tiny beings
that are that like like to like eat
force like fraggles right those little
things like fraggles that built the the
all the structures yeah
in like
dozers
like to see like how like they work and
like what if like midichlorians could
get like bigger and become aliens and
[ __ ] like what would that look like mtu
would have got that answer but all of
these fans got mad at george you know
what he did he sold it he sold it away
to disney and they're never gonna answer
the question and now we just call it an
m count we just call it an m count now
and we don't even mention it again yeah
we could have found out if we were nicer
to george i really hope they get into it
like in like uh you know the mandalorian
because like that's sort of has like a
weird clone narrative there and like i
just want to see
what the midichlorians mean and like how
they factor in because like they they
are canon the empire like i said the m
count stuff they actually have a way to
measure and detect so we just don't know
what that looks like right
yeah i want i
i hope they're taking i hope i hope
they're taking all these kids i think i
i hope that ties into like mandalorian
or even like the you know like uh the
force awakens like snope and stuff i i
hope it's like
it's it's part of like the emperor's
like clone program where he's like i
don't necessarily want to rely on clones
my whole life like maybe if i can find
force sensitive children i can hop into
their bodies when i need to or so i can
find like the perfect host yeah well
that was an arc in um in the clone wars
animated show uh palpatine hired cad
bane to go out and start kidnapping for
sensitive children and that's one of the
theories of where his pipeline of
inquisitors came from uh as all these
children that he captured early
brainwashed and then was able to make
his own little uh sith army or not sith
army yeah i went like i want like
numbers too like what percentage of the
population is force sensitive at any
time because when we were watched like
the prequels there was like hundreds of
kids going to this university at the
jedi temple and that can't even be all
of them right there's got to be plenty
that slip under the radar or their
parents are like i'm not sending you to
to corcerant to be a the jedi temple i
don't like the jedi we live all the way
out here on yeah
rather stay here and just send me and
make and boo bop beep and i'd rather
just fly food into my mouth on the couch
right yeah i don't want to go to school
to be a jedi
and then from the kid's point of view
like obi-wan's like yeah i think i
remember my parents and i think i had a
brother yeah like it's it's pretty
jarring for the kids right i would
imagine yeah i'm hoping that uh speaking
of the animated shows so i'm hoping that
this theory might be what i'm gonna call
rogue so bear with me here but uh
yeah i know right i hate it
i'm gonna i'm sorry jess i'm gonna do it
snap your neck
um i
i would love i was trying to think of it
too like how would they know and uh one
thing that came up from rebels was this
this world between worlds this kind of
time portal realm yeah palpatine
world between worlds right and so if
palpatine can like look through this
looking glass of time somehow and and
and to get ahsoka and ezra he could
maybe he could look in to see when are
these force sensitive kids coming up and
and go through it maybe reach through
time and through the force through his
dark sith magic to find out where these
kids are how to get to them and maybe
that's why it's not so accurate because
i think what they've established in the
world between worlds is that it kind of
is what it is it's not necessarily like
a magic eight ball right
so maybe palpatine is yeah using that to
somehow peer through
time through the force to find where
these kids are because the only the way
he did it in the clone wars cartoon was
uh they stole a jedi holocron which had
information on where all the force
sensitive kids were in the galaxy but
then when that got destroyed then that
was kind of then that path was closed so
i was trying to think how else would he
do it so i wonder if we know the world
between world is going to come back
somehow it'd be cool if in live action
we get to see it but that's how he's
able to find out where all these kids
are
that is such a clever idea i've never
really thought about that because like
and i'm a bit like a lot of people don't
really like the the world between world
and how like that was introduced but
like i honestly feel like
that's going to come into play in like
the future star wars
yeah haters i honestly feel like that's
going to come into play because like we
have all these like heroes from
different like time periods we have the
mandalorian and we have like obi-wan and
all that stuff and like even though like
obviously time travel doesn't have to
come into play not everything has to be
avengers end game obviously but i feel
like we're gonna get a weird avengers
endgame type of scenario with star wars
and have like a really dope team up
through um the this uh world between
worlds maybe like but look forward
through or something yeah exactly like
just one big star wars star war everyone
would love it and like it would be the
what's the best thing ever like imagine
like imagine freaking um like kylo ren
and like versus darth vader and like
freaking the mandalorian this is super
smash bros
star wars yeah what's going on
smashed have we talked about this kylo
ren versus darth vader kylo
he's i mean so is anakin but like kylo
ren's a real baby he's such a brag
no and anakin would be like oh my god
settle i mean he kind of he kind of has
a point this goes back to like not
knowing
about and anakin was darth vader right
no one told ben
that his his grandfather was the the
biggest killer in the galaxy and he
finds out as like a teenager and he's
like what the hell no one thought to
mention this to me and that's why he
gets pissed and he starts down that dark
path because han and leia
not great parents uh they didn't have
great examples as parents that's fair i
get that they're not great parents
themselves
they hit it from the boy uh and it
pisses me i prefer i ship uh luke and
leia actually um i'm from alabama all
right
that's why you're in incognito mode all
the time
incognito mode all the time brandon's
right
huh okay okay
your mind
can look at my history expressvpn keeps
music like she's like it is christian it
is christian there's a lot of incest
that's why empty added that flavor on to
sister when he's like the sister yeah
that's why empty was
that was because that was stripped
you are gross
disgusting
[Laughter]
but no i really i really love this idea
of like the world between worlds and the
emperor using it to find these kids it
just makes a lot of sense and like i
feel like it could happen so i'm gonna
give you
forty thousand points for that one that
was
really freaking good i love it i mean
like i love like and you did you bring
up the holocron part because like that's
a huge
tool like that palpatine was using to
just find all these kids like he's
looking for these jedi holocrons that
are basically just lists of where all
these um
all the kids that the jedi found before
they were destroyed
and um and so like he just uses those to
find even more which is super messed up
i don't know why the jedi had like all
those lists of children and just didn't
pick them up but already it's kind of
weird that they just had like
like imagine like children yeah it's
like what are you guys doing you heard
that like the jedi just have your son's
name
somewhere it's like why do you
why are you looking into my son you
creep exactly um but yeah no because the
jedi were bad and they deserved to be
destroyed
they really did they weren't the best
they were kind of just from brandon's
point of view the jedi are evil
thank you thank you
that's that's late stage star wars
fandom is when you realize the jedi are
the problem and they need to go but then
when luke when luke said that in last
jedi the fans got mad again
i think i think people when they they're
thinking about the jedi they're like oh
like they're thinking of just people
that have the force in general and i'm
like no it's the people that were the
organizations yeah the organ the jedi
sitting in that circle at the top yeah
yeah yeah yeah there was not a
it was everybody else right like both
the jedi and the sith are just religion
gone wrong both of them and like it's
like just use the force
as it is just like do what qui-gon was
doing he's like i'm just chilling with
the living force it's just i'm just i
just love it it's dope
but like you know they just yeah just
live on bebop boob up and put food in
your mouth that's all you got to do with
the force end of the story the anakin
tries to when he floats that fruit and
attack of the clones
exactly that's the way you do it you use
the force to flirt that's how you're
supposed to do it and nothing else
um but of course i loved your your joint
theory together both of you so i want to
give both of you 35 000 points
because you guys are smart cookies
team jandin is at it again
but now it is time for our
rogue question are you guys ready for it
because we're going to talk about
hayden christensen a very nice man a
very handsome man i'm glad he's back in
the star wars universe because hayden
christensen took his victory lap at star
wars celebration last week and recently
said that he is absolutely on board to
do a darth vader spin-off series so i
want all of you to pitch me your rogus
version for the spin-off series but in a
totally different style from all the
other star wars shows that we've had so
far
go extra rogue with this i want to see
what you guys got for a darth vader show
this is my thought is rogue but it has
been happen and i think it was a great
idea and they should do it again snl did
a very funny sketch that was like the
secret boss the underground
cover box
i would love to see randy can do
undercover pause
and i want him to work every day as like
a storm trooper put them inside of like
a protocol droid's body or whatever like
yeah
and then you put them in a storm trooper
and then you just keep putting them in
different things that cover his body you
could probably fit him inside of an r2
unit right you could still see his cape
hanging out yeah exactly he's got like
half a stormtrooper helmet be like i'm
just have you seen the new tk16 whatever
and people are mean to him and he's just
like i hate this place
he just starts
knocks them over this would work even
better with the fortress inquisitorius
with all the inquisitors he's like i'm
not darth vader i'm the seventh brother
i'm the 18th cousin
any of the marvel star wars any of them
should do like a little short of a
reality series where they're doing like
the undercover boss or they're doing
like a real
world it's just
what's the bunk house like for the
inquisitors
i feel like you're in the way
you don't have ears all of my sugar
without replacing oh my god no
they should do big brother big brother
and sisters
so did you hear that the fifth brother
and the big sister hooked up
oh my god
we should vote them out next week i am
head of household this week
[Laughter]
i want darth i want darth vader's series
to be
you know stanley tucci's series on cnn
is very popular right now go into it yes
it is i love it
i want darth vader to do a travel show
where he he ventures back to tatooine
and he he tries all the local delicacies
oh i love that moisture farmers this is
always gonna be like cribs too it's
gonna be like here's my front of my cave
the surprising part about this is
brandon hates going back to tattooing
but he wants more tattooing
they showed up when they showed up on
moosa pop or whatever it was called and
it kind of looked like a desert planet i
was like get out of here
but yeah he could even go back he could
go back to the sand people the the
tuscan raiders with like a bouquet of
flowers and be like i'm sorry i'm so
sorry guys i really messed up boy bad so
yeah i want the darth vader travel
series that's what i want yes i don't
know have you guys ever seen a travel
man with um richard
ayuarde oh yeah yeah yeah
oh my god i want to see that with darth
vader that would be hilarious everyone's
just scared of him like please don't
kill me
show me how you deep fried these
tauntauns
i've never had a swamp
this is tasty
they're like shaking and peeing their
pants
and i just want to see him lift his mask
and like take a bite and just burn mouth
right
or a straw that goes right through the
gate of his front thing
what you got tom
so i want to see
darth vader you know star wars is a show
about family
and and you never leave family behind
and i want to see a pod racing driving
darth vader movie that's all about
family i want to go back to tattooing
and he would be like i live my life a
quarter parsec at a time
and then he could race like other people
in the galaxy and then it's gonna be
like mario kart where they travel to
other worlds having grand prix
racing and then they'll become soldiers
in space they're already in space or
maybe they'll go to earth maybe because
that'll be the opposite of what the fast
is doing but either way either way i
want them to do fast and or the tooth
sith too too furious
uh four through four
because there's a rule of two
and we'll just pretend you didn't watch
the first one yeah exactly two sith too
furious
it's like a perfect life crisis
it's like you gotta get back into grace
that's what i was doing
okay this obviously sounds like a joke
idea but like i can see darth vader
doing this like i can see him sneaking
out like wearing a disguise and like
just wanting to race like as a normal
person like in like
it doesn't even need to wear the sky
it's gonna be like dude this burn victim
wants to race like i'll just look we
won't even need a disguise to be like
this guy they're like we should let him
do like yeah let him do it that'll smoke
everybody now this is pod racing again
these are all amazing ideas but i really
like this idea of pod racing vader i dig
it a lot because like he's a racer at
the end of the day he's the best pilot
in the galaxy and i can totally see him
just like wanting to just race even
though his uh his daddy palpatine
palpatine is like no no no you're
supposed to sit in your egg and think
all day your little thinking pod um
100 000
million points
i would be happy with one wow 100 000
million thank you
yes making tom our winner for this rogue
theory for today
good job tom
you are an amazing person but of course
all of your theories are amazing jess
and brandon i love you both um what a
pleasure i love talking a little bit
extra today
i love you guys all but this expires
tomorrow tomorrow empty will go back to
not loving me as much so don't worry
everybody this is a 24-hour spell he
receives a minute i choose one person to
love a day and then everyone else is on
my [ __ ] list
um
but that is it for this episode of rogue
theory thanks to our amazing guests
jessica clemens tom michaelson and
off-screen producer brandon support them
on all their twitters and everything
that they do like for fun and like you
know just they're all amazing people and
you can also support our channel by
checking out all of our amazing merch
options over at newrockstarsmerch.com
and if you've got some rogue theories of
your own share them on our discord what
are you doing click the link in the
description box and just join the
conversation there because we would love
to have you but you got to be 18 years
old or older or else you know because
what we're going to say is probably some
some bad words
just kidding um just in case we do you
gotta be 18 years old builder um and you
can follow me on entertainment if you
want to see me tweet some weird [ __ ] and
then follow new rock charts wherever we
are on social platforms make sure you
hit the notification bell so you get
notifications every time we upload a
video thank you guys so much for
watching again we love you guys so much
and we'll see you guys next time goodbye
bye
[Music]
you